We have a voicemail number.
That number is 2 1 9 2.
David P..
A couple of voicemails today going to try
to insert a little bit of levity and some
less serious topics at a time.
That is that is a challenging one for all
of us.
Let's take a listen to the first voicemail
today.
Hi, David Packman.
And this is Aaron.
I was just kind of curious why I only hear
men calling in, as you can hear in the background.
Only a man.
But anyway, it would be interesting to see
what women have to say.
Right, as well.
Anyway, I love your show and I love the success
you're having.
So have a good day.
Yeah.
This is actually less about our show.
We are the ad agency.
Our ad sales program has ex-spy expanded into
an ad agency and we actually represent a lot
of online talk shows for ad sales and all
of our demographics for political online shows
skew male.
This is not something unique to the David
Packman show.
In fact, we have more of a female audience
than many other shows that are in our cohort
that are similar shows to ours.
And it's something about the format, even
shows that have a bigger female presence.
Hosting wise often have a smaller female audience
than our show.
Then we work with other other types of shows
that have a much more balanced audience gender
wise as far as that goes.
So that is that is an interesting thing.
All right.
One other voicemail.
That's just kind of a funny, funny allusion
to Susan Collins, the perennially disappointed
Republican senator.
David, I to say, I'm supplying the show today.
I haven't listened to it or anything.
I just know it's going to be disappointing.
Right.
All right.
Thanks.
Well, listen, I apologize that I'm letting
people down.
In all seriousness, it has been I don't know
if heart warming is the right term.
It feels sort of apocryphal to call it that,
a cliche in a sense.
But I have been so thrilled to see that in
what are very difficult times for a lot of
people for four large portions of the country
that are actually doing what we need to do
to try to deal with coronavirus that so many
people have been getting in touch and saying
what you're providing is a really valuable
service.
Thanks for staying on top of the virus.
Thanks for staying on top of politics while
all of this is going on.
Thanks for rearranging production in a way
to allow all of this to continue.
The livestreams week we streamed yesterday's
Trump Corona virus press conference across
YouTube, Twitch and Facebook.
We had about sixteen thousand live viewers,
which for us that's a great live stream for
us.
So there's clearly a desire to have information.
We're doing everything we can to provide it
to people and we're going to continue and
it continues tonight.
I hope you'll join me at 8:00 p.m. Eastern
for the primary results live stream on the
bonus show today.
We are going to dig in more, not to the U.S.
stock market collapse, but the world's stock
market collapse.
Europe.
Asia and and others and I have a few personal
stories to tell you about it.
Also, it's not just toilet paper that people
are hoarding.
People are starting to buy guns and ammo over
concerns around martial law may maybe being
declared leading to people having to fend
for themselves in a way that might require
guns.
Now, the funny thing about it or ironic is
often when martial law is declared.
Guns are sometimes seized.
So we'll talk about that.
And then lastly, Mitt Romney has a corona
virus plan that sounds a lot like Andrew Yangs.
Thousand bucks a month, universal basic income
plan.
So we will talk about all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show.
Grab a membership at join Packman dot com
or make a patriotic pledge at Patry on dot
com slash David Packman show to get instant
access.
I will speak to that.